do you wish you an avatar
dude I know a guy that's in that [ __ ]
movie and I see his house he lives in my
neighborhood and I think he uh what the
checks that he cashes from being in that
[ __ ] movie which guy
his name is Joel David Moore
you ever see Grandma's Boy yeah of
course oh he's the he's the top yeah I
love that guy he's so funny man yeah he
was an avatar and every time I see him
I'm always like what the [ __ ] does that
pay you out a year because it's and
that's an endless stream of residuals
he's in Avatar one yeah I think he's
both no he's in both he's in both yeah
he's in both yeah I got to see a picture
that's where that's when you when you
that's the proverbial lottery in
Hollywood someone's like you hit the
lottery it's [ __ ] like that where you're
like I'm part of a franchise well
because you but but you became one of
the ones that's like forever embedded in
the history of film like you'll never
not make money on that for 100 oh he was
in DodgeBall too he's a funny guy man
very funny he's so [ __ ] okay how is
Hollywood reacting to Avatar have you
seen it yet no it okay
I want to know about Hollywood reaction
to it but first before I just want to
talk about for a second it is the reason
why we go to the movies I saw it avatars
yeah but regardless of if you like the
story or not like some people like Oh I
thought the story was traditional or
whatever I don't really care about that
I love story it's the most important
thing but the spectacle of it all to me
I thought the story is fine it was it
was great but the spectacle the world
that you're brought into the Escape that
it creates
is magnificent and no I I like me I know
what you mean it was the same reason
that I say Top Gun for me was like 100
visually you want to see something
that's that's what Hollywood returns to
like he said topical is the greatest
movie he's ever seen I think it's the
greatest movie he said it's the greatest
story of any movies ever seen that part
is totally wrong I mean it's not one of
the best visual things I didn't say that
you did you did I said it's the greatest
movie story that's ever
it's probably one of the greatest visual
things I've I've seen and Visually I
wasn't even that Blown Away
what do you
I'm wearing my shades no no I thought
taka was absolutely fantastic it's safe
movies I thought it was great for what
it was
don't do that don't do that I thought it
was great for what it was what is that
it's a blockbuster and it's a great
Blockbuster I didn't think it was the
greatest story but kind of like Avatar
when you go to the theaters if I want to
see a great movie a great story I'll see
it at home would I if I want to see a
blockbuster I'm going to the theater
yeah if it's visual you have to go to
this let me clarify with Top Gun what I
said is it is a traditional hero's
journey story okay what I said is it's
executed to Perfection that's the little
thing I said is this is traditional
Hollywood Blockbuster executed to
Perfection it wasn't I and I
specifically compared it to everything
everywhere ever whatever once or
whatever that was something that I'd
never be able to say that movie uh but
that's a good movie it's a phenomenal
movie different story completely
different type of Storytelling yeah okay
you look at that big wow this is
something I haven't seen before it's not
traditional Top Gun is traditional and
executed to Perfection it is it is yeah
but but also but also it's like well I'm
turning this ringer off but also my my
problem with it is uh
it's it's a it's recalling all these
feelings you had because of Top Gun one
say you weren't in it bro I'm not saying
that's the problem you should have been
one of those guys pissed did you go up
for it no no you didn't even think about
you
why do you think that they looked at
your headshot and then just tore it in
half okay I don't know about that that's
they didn't even look at it they didn't
they're like santinos had shot and they
[ __ ] threw it right back you think
they knew your name you know what those
people think they said Santino's
headshot or you think they just saw red
hair and then threw it those people
those people those definitely knew you
they knew my name they definitely did no
you know what that's the kind of stuff
that's this is the hard weird line of
Hollywood of being a comedian is you're
inherently always
discounted for those things you have to
push like Jonah Hill used to talk about
it a lot nobody took him serious yeah
he's strong and they didn't want to like
get him in those movies well no but you
know what I mean like they wanted him to
be a funny dude for that guy I mean he
really I know what you're saying yeah
but no truth be told they don't really
love to I think of comics in those
worlds they're like no no there's other
real actors that do that that's the way
they look at it you're not a real actor
dude well most Comics aren't Leading Men
yeah that's just the reality
they don't want you to be one of the
Pilots That's not those aren't those
other guys are just called one of those
black guys a banana
that's kind of what it feels like tell
me I'm wrong
no no no no no no
they don't they wouldn't let you be they
wouldn't let you be four fifth sixth
down the list because they don't see you
like that yeah you're not you're a
comedian guy so when you have to sucker
them into can you convince them and your
agents people go dude you have to see
him for this thing like I'm up for this
[ __ ] this movie uh that I want really
[ __ ] bad can you get us an audition
thing I want it bad stuff can you get us
something yeah yeah and I had to do a
Boston accent and all this [ __ ] and I
really wanted it bad and I'm still in
the mix for it but it's way bigger than
me like can you tell us what the movie
had too it's Ted Ted two ten three ten
three yeah oh there was a tattoo oh yeah
and I wasn't in that [ __ ] either
can you say what it is a movie and then
we bleep it no but I can just I mean
it's a it's I mean Matt Damon is it's
him so they say no more and when they
when they showed me the whole thing I
was like holy [ __ ] this is like a lot of
scenes in this movie
and they were like yeah and they like
you for it so I did the tape and they
were like okay we're gonna talk after
the new year so now I'm kind of waiting
in the wings to find out what the [ __ ]
the next movie like I'm willing to just
be like I'll come down to Boston I'll
come back to Boston and go sit with you
guys you want me to sit because
sometimes that's what's weird when
you're on my level you have to go like
really sell yourself to them and be like
here's why I can be of value instead a
guy's like Miles Teller and all those I
mean do they get calls yo you can't we
want you okay word but for us there's
this weird like don't they just tell you
that it's like no dude you have to be a
Salesman of like you should here's how I
can do it yeah you should try the
opposite that's worked really well for
me oh yeah where they ask you to be in
the movie yeah and then you go ugh I
don't want to do it and then they put
you and then they just keep asking right
and then keep making it worth more money
you call my age tell them try that yeah
yeah yeah tell Matt Damon to suck a dick
[ __ ] off never works again
I think that's the they don't consider
you for they don't think about you yeah
like well they can tell you want it
yeah well because I was but I was they
don't know what to do when someone
doesn't want it or doesn't need it yeah
in a lot of ways it's not like the Pete
Davidson thing where like Pete didn't
really he always had that attitude of
like and God blessed him for it he was I
watched it I don't know maybe yeah it
was [ __ ] amazing they were like maybe
yeah yeah
so I guess like I understand a piece
that but with stuff like this I want it
because I wanna I wanna have another
I want to transition a little bit out of
Comedy sometimes you know I mean like
that my favorite comedic actors were
always good enough to do other things
and not just stay in comedy [ __ ] like
when Jim Carrey left being Jim Carrey
for a little while I loved it dude yeah
that was very cool he didn't have a
choice but to kind of come back a little
bit and then that Bert Wonderstone movie
was
so you went out of this game you went
out of Comedy no I want to be able to I
want to be able to dip my feet in both
babies
yeah that was a good question yeah
that's why it's good it comes out of
left field you never saw that sometimes
it comes out of right field no you know
what I do you're not gonna even know
where this is I want I want a little bit
you have no clue what I'm about to ask
oh go ahead
you I don't even know yet
I don't even know it's gonna be best on
the next thing that you said okay okay
go
um
and I want to [ __ ] switch it up a
little bit I don't want to I like doing
movies like house party and all this I
shouldn't be in these but I do want
something else that's like makes me feel
different and then also legitimizes you
for other [ __ ] I need it Biden
no thanks
now you can play Biden you'd be a good
you could be Biden you need an amazing
button yeah his biopic
what are we gonna do about Ukraine Mr
President well you gotta you gotta
understand dude what part of the reason
I've never been on a uh you know growing
up in Connecticut
blacks smell funny
come on that guy said that guy has done
such a disservice talking whenever they
get him to talk it makes me sad don't
let him talk yeah Stephen Hawking have
you seen have you heard the [ __ ]
yeah would you say an in-bomb as a
character yeah of course
I wouldn't even think twice if Tarantino
wrote that down she told me to say now
would you would you riff one let's say
your character was a racist okay let's
say you're doing his team okay you're
doing Curb Your Enthusiasm you're
playing a racist where there's no lines
you have to riff you're a racist or you
drop 100 I'm not even thinking about it
you said be the guy I'll be the guy what
do you want me to do he wants it Andrew
you think you think a guy in the KKK
holds himself back from saying it yeah I
think so
he's like let me tell you something
about these
boys I'm trying to reserve myself yeah
you know I think I think they're words
for it I think they figured out oh
they've got new slangs exactly because
damn word is just like well that's old
yeah they got some good ones they've got
some good ones yeah yeah yeah I saw one
that was real somebody said uh Russell
on his Def Jam said one they called him
Mondays because nobody likes it nobody
likes money someone said there was like
a meme that was like look at all these
burnt ends and I was like oh my god wow
that was tough that was genius say
something that you say regularly yes I
mean that is smart yeah just do that
right there it was quick